We also learned about planning--in particular, breadth-first planning,
A-star planning, and dynamic programming planning
that all address slightly different use cases.
Those are being used to plan the trajectory of the Google Street-View car
and the Darpa Grand Challenge cars.
In fact, you implemented a good number of those, which is quite amazing.
Here is my quiz for planning.
You learned about breadth first, A-star, dynamic programming,
and for the sake of this comparison I will also include the smoother,
which is more like plan refinement.
Check any or all of those boxes if the corresponding planner
acts in a continuous space, if it finds an optimal solution,
if it's a universal plan--
that means the solution, once found, can be applied to arbitrary states--
or if the solution is local, which means given an approximate initial solution,
it cannot really do anything more than just locally refine the solution.